>>OSINGA:
Good, uh, afternoon, um, you're here at the
Waving across the Web talk, my name is uh,
Douwe Osinga, this is Dhanji, we're both engineers
on the API team, and we want to talk to you
today about Wave, and what you can do with
it outside of Wave. Um, just a brief refresher
on, uh, Wave, getting stuff done with groups
of people is our new slogan. Um, we have the,
the, the Wave panel, on the, on the right
side, and um, the inbox on the, on the left
side. Our talk is mostly about what you can
do with Wave outside of this whole thing,
so, uh, in as far as you've seen the Wave
client, it will be mostly, uh, the Wave panel
itself. Yes, as with all sessions there is
a Live Waving session, a session with this
if you can follow this link here, you'll on
land there, you can ask questions in the embedded
gidget there. You can start commenting on
things at the bottom, and we have somebody
in the audience who's actually typing in what
I'm saying.
So, what are we talking about today. Um, last
year when we announced Wave, we announced
our APIs too and they were mostly focused
on extensions APIs, so there were things that
you can do to make the Wave experience richer,
so that's on one hand Robots and on the other
hand Gadgets. If you want to learn more about
that, then, well, partly you missed your chance,
because the talk about how you built extensions
was uh, this afternoon, but tomorrow there's
uh, one that goes deeper into the Robot API
so if you want to learn that, make sure to
not miss that one. This year, we um, have
expanded our APIs and a lot of those APIs
are around using the Wave API outside of Wave
so we already had an embedding client but
uh we've expanded what you can do with it
and Dhanji will talk more about that. Well,
look at that. Um, I have an extra slide. So,
Dhanji will talk more about the, how we use
the embedded client and how you can use it
for commenting on the Web. I'll then talk
some more about Wave This, which is a content-sharing
mechanism that we have set up with some interesting
features, how you can use the role of API
to display data from, from Wave on outside
of the Wave client and I'll introduce the
Wave Data APIs which we think are fairly exciting,
because they allow you as the developer to
uh, get direct access to the users Wave data
and it allows you to build anything from notifiers
in Chrome to lightweight clients for platforms
like Android. Now, I think.
>>DHANJI:
Okay, hello everyone. Um, so I'm going to
talk to you today about embedding Waves. Up
until now we've had this concept of: you come
to Google Wave, you open your inbox, you open
your inbox, you look around to see what's
changed, then, you interact with other people
and then you go away. Embedding is sort of
the reverse of this. We take Google Wave and
bring it to you. So, you embed Google Waves
out there, in your own websites, in your own
blogs, and other pages that you use. So, to
start with, let's look at a couple of use
cases for where you might want to do this.
So, commenting is quite a popular meme on
the web. You've got blogs that have comments,
news articles have comments, just about any
kind of article that describes a particular
topic has a comment thread associated with
it where readers can come in and post their
thoughts. This has sort of been around for
about fifteen years now, and it's really starting
to show signs of wear.
Traditional commenting is slow because you
have to post something and then come back
a couple of hours later and see if anybody's
replied, it's all totally asynchronous you
know, it's kinda like sending emails to each
other in a public forum. They're generally
linearly structured, so one comment comes
after another, although some commenting systems
out there allow you to do slightly better
structuring for replies, and many of them
don't allow you to make any corrections or
delete comments if you uh, had second thoughts
about them. And of course there's no great
way to put in any rich comment, or put in
any rich content, rather, into these comments,
without linking offsite. And that's quite
a poor experience for someone who's reading
through a list of comments and wants to kind
of get the full experience and wants to get
the full experience of the comment and everything
it's talking about without leaving the conversation.
So, all of this isn't a great way to have
a conversation about a topic. It's kind of
worked well so far, but we believe that there's
a better way.
So, Wave is a commenting system instantly
has some benefits, right? Because everything
happens in real time, you can build a conversation
just as you would in a room, sitting around
with a bunch of friends. So when you say something
about, about the article that the comment
thread is in, someone can jump in immediately
and reply to that. And you can reply to that
reply, so forth. And it's all instantaneous;
it's a real conversation taking place. You
can of course edit the existing comments you
can edit even other people's comments, so,
I know there's some uh, grammar freaks out
there that like to correct people's grammar,
so you can get in there and make those corrections.
Other people can edit your comments, and maybe
add some more context around what you were
saying. And all of this is available via playback,
so you don't lose any of the history of the
conversation as you're going through it. And
that's a real good saving.
So, all this makes for a real good conversation
rather than this asynchronous mass of messages
that are being posted and glued together in
a string. And of course, the real benefit
is that you can embed rich content. Everything
from videos and images to maps and of course
Gadgets which is one of our really cool features
that allows you to do things like take spot-polls
or run/ insert drawing that people can interactively
build in your comment thread.
Alright, so let's move onto another use case,
actually before that, this is a quick example
of a comment thread, of basically a Wave with
a lot of activity on it. You can see that
there's a base document that's right in the
back with, um, some pictures on it and there's
people replying in line to the things that
they want to make a point about. And the colored
blocks that you see there are the cursors
of the various people actually replying in
real time. And it is really quite exciting
to kinda see this conversation unfold.
Ok, so the other terrific use-case for embedded
Waves is an Event. So, like you had the keynote
this morning, or you'll see the second keynote
tomorrow with the two big surprises they have
planned, you can sort of broadcast what's
happening in real time, using a Wave. Traditionally,
you'd have a techjournalist or reporter who'd
come in, sort of an exclusive set of people
that get to sit right up front, they digest
everything that's being said, take, they get
like an official set of screenshots that they
can publish, and then you get all this information
packaged in and put out to you on their blog,
maybe four or five hours later. And it's not
really a great experience because you don't
get the feel of what's going on live. Um,
there are of course multiple competing sources
for this kind of thing, and each blogger or
techjournalist has their own perspective and
uh, you have to kind of read all of them to
get a comprehensive view of what's going on.
And of course there's no reader interaction,
right? It's completely one-way; it's all one-directional.
It's whatever the reporter or the journalist
thinks, uh, that you're going to, that you're
going to get. You can't ask them questions,
you can't sort of point out mistakes they've
made, and if they've forgotten something,
that's lost forever, that information's not
going to happen. Twitter and Buzz have become
popular substitutes for broadcasting things
that have become real-time Events. Uh, so
when the iPad launched, there was all kinds
of crazy activity on Twitter and Buzz. So,
the, it's clearly time for something better.
We call this Live Waving, and you would have
seen earlier there's a link where there's
a Live Wave for this very talk, you can kinda
see how this works. But what Live Waving is,
is bringing the realtime aspect of an Event
to users. So, a blog journalist or a, sorry,
a techjournalist or a blogger can get on there
and start putting in what they, what their
thoughts are, what their observations are
and people can jump on there along with everyone
else, and ask questions or put in their perspective,
and multiple journalists or multiple sources,
are no longer singularly authoritative, right?
LIke, if you disagree with something they're
saying, you can kinda go in there, point that
out. And uh, and this takes kind of what the
Twitter users and the Buzz users have done
organically and like brings it into one comprehensive,
robust platform. And we think that live waving
is really a quite used case for Wave.
Of course the great thing about Live Waving
is that because it's a regular Wave, you can
pull in all kinds of rich content. So you
can put in screenshots of the great new anndroid
handset, or uh video of it in action or, whatever
that might be. Ok, so what is an embedded
Wave? An embedded Wave is just the Wave client,
the normal regular Wave client, without everything
outside the Wave. So, it's just that little
bit that contains the Wave and its content.
You can embed that in any website; be it a
small snippet of JavaScript, and this is exactly
how YouTube works with their little snippet
of HTML which you can use to embed the flash
player. So this is what it looks like; there's
a Google common JavaScript loader interface
that we use, it's just a simple script tag
that you put in the top of your page, and
then that allows you to call the Google dot
load method, and we see Google dot load, Wave
One, which means gimme the first version of
the Wave API. And then we construct ourselves
a Wave panel, using Google dot Wave dot Wave
panel, and uh we point it to a div on the
page, so you can just create any div on the
page with a width and height that, that's
to your preference, and then point the Wave
panel to it. Finally, we call Load Wave with
the WaveID, which tells the script to go and
pick up particular Wave to stick in there.
So, here's an example a screenshot of an actual
embedded Wave and this comes from Mashables,
the Wave API challenge that they ran last
month; very successful challenge that they
ran. And what they did was they ran this contest
where they got people to write great extensions
for Wave, and they disseminated all the information
by putting it in a Wave and allowing people
to look at it in a read-only fashion. And
this worked out really well. And of course
the UI of the embedded Wave is pretty easily
customized. I said earlier you can specify
the width and the height of the div, and the
Wave sort of expands to fill that region correctly,
but you can also add some CSS properties.
You can change the color of the font, you
can change the background color, you can set
whether or not there's a header there. Um,
so, in this example there is no header, but
earlier in this example, with a full Wave
client, you kinda see the list of participants,
and a toolbar underneath. And you can get
that as well.
Ok, so let's quickly look at a demo of this
in action. And this is just me with the Wave
client open, and uh, this is a webpage and
I've stuck that snippet of JavaScript that
I showed you earlier, into this HTML page,
there's not a whole lot to it, it's like a
fake blog that I came up with, um and this
bit right here is the WaveID that I've pulled
out of the normal Wave client by using the
link-to-Wave feature. So you see here at the
bottom, there's a little WaveID, and you can
copy and paste that. In here. And call load
Wave on it, to bring the Wave up. Alright.
So let's see this in action... So here we
go. So this is my little bog, and then I embedded
a Wave in it, and remember that this is a
fully functional first-class entity, so this
is a real Wave, and you can reply to it and
do all the things that you do in a normal
Wave. So, for instance, let's say that I was
a random reader of Blogtastic, I could come
in here, and put in a reply.
[pause]
And then this reply shows up here. And of
course, I can reply the other way, and that
shows up here too. And of course it has all
the other features of Wave, like adding Gadgets,
and images, and video. Okay, let's get back
to our demo; our presentation. Okay. So, this
other cool feature that we rolled out recently
was allowing people to look at an embedded
Wave even if they didn't have a Google Wave
account. So, up until now if you came across
an embedded Wave in the wild, you have to
be logged in to be able to see the content.
This makes, makes for kind of poor experience
if you know you just haven't logged in or
your session's expired or something like that.
So we've added this thing called anonymous
embed, which allows any public Wave, so any
Wave with a public participant on it, to be
viewed by just about anyone at all. And you
can kinda see in the top right there's this,
instead of the username, you have anonymous,
and there's a link to log in. And uh, as of
today we have open signup, so, even if you
didn't have Google Wave invite, you can click
log in and you can sign yourself up. And that's
terrific.
And this is exactly what Mashable uh, did,
and they've been able to take advantage of
the fact that anyone can now come in and look
at a Wave and then go ahead, interact with
it, if they want to. So this feature that
I've just demonstrated is slightly clunky
for a use-case where you want to embed Waves
in several websites, right? So, if I just
wanted to do it in one thing, in one Wave,
in one page, that's not a huge problem. I
can copy/paste the WaveID in my uh, HTML,
like I did here, and everything's fine. But
if I want to do, say, five or ten of these,
then it's quite cumbersome to go through and
copy and paste and pre-create all of these
Waves. So we came up with this thing called
myEmbed. It's just a little name I have for
it, it's not anything official. And what you
do with myEmbed is instead of having a WaveID
you register an owner. So if I'm the webmaster,
my name is Champ, I write my owner address
in the little snippet of JavaScript itself.
So, now when the embed Wave comes up, it looks
to make sure that you're the one who's actually
trying to view this Wave. And if no one's
seen it before, it creates the Wave if it's
not there. And the way in which it does this,
and completely skirts around the issue of
the WaveID, is by looking at the containing
page's URL. So we take the containing page's
URL and convert it into a WaveID internally,
and that's all sort of hidden from you, so
you don't' have to worry about it. And make
sure that you are the same user as the one
specified in the owner address. So, that's
fairly nice. And of course this means that
you can just take this little JavaScript snippet
and stick it in all of your WebPages and you
just need to visit your WebPages one by one
and make sure that they're working, and the
Waves get created for you automatically. Ok,
so uh, the simplest way to get going with
embedded Waves is to go to the Google Web
Elements website.
The Google Web Elements website is just a
simple way to look at all of our APIs and
sort of play with them, and get helloworlds
going with them. And you can find that at
google.com/webelements. And, we're right at
the bottom there, at slash Wave. Ok, so uh,
Douwe's going to show you some cool extensions,
and things we can do with Robots, and there's
another talk tomorrow about our new Robot
API and our liberated Robots, so Robots can
now run on any domain, not just uh, on an
app engine. So what I did, just before this
talk, was wrote up a little lightweight embedded
Wave client…let me show you this in a second.
And I did this purely using our Robot API.
So this is a real Wave and I pointed it to
a Wave ID and the server's running on my desktop,
on my laptop, sorry. And it loaded instantly.
So it tells you that you can pretty much do
everything that we do with the regular Wave
client, with our APIs. And that's really our
goal, is to power you guys. Ok! Thank you.
[Applause]
>>OSINGA:
If you thought this was all bad news, I have
more slides. So Wave This! Um, a lot of services
have this dig/publish/start with it, a little
button on the page, and if you click it you
can share whatever URL you came from with
your friends through some mechanism. And in
fact, this goes back to even the Mailto link
that allows you to do things like that. And
of course, we wanted to have one too, and
it works exactly as you um, expect it to work.
You click the thing. It gives you a little
uh, little in-between screen, to confirm that
you actually want to do this, to avoid you
know, people to spam you that way, and it
creates a Wave with a link back to that page
that you came from. And you can add your friends,
and you can start discussing what's on this
thing. And, um…there's a bunch of parameters
that you can set, of course, the URL, if you
don't set the URL it will um, it will take
the refer URL so the same way the My Embed
trick, you don't actually have to specify
URL you can just drop the same thing. Um,
you can specify the title for the Wave, and
you can specify the, the content, the initial
bit of content, so this you could take from
your blog template or something like that.
Since it goes over the URL, unfortunately,
you run into the 2k limit so you can't really
put a lot of content in there. But the interesting
feature, and this is why I'm fairly excited
about this, it's good and takes this a lot
further than most of the sharing things that
you have, is that you can specify gadget.
So how does it work? So, in this example I
have um a Wavethis link, that refers from
a YouTube watch page, and it specifies a,
it specifies a Wavethis public youtube.xml
as a Gadget. Now, if I click this thing, and
as always we hope that the network plays nice.
Right, so it asks me if it's okay that youtube.com
wants to create a Wave with me, and I say,
sure. Otherwise it would be short demo. And
um, it loads the Wave client; it loads the
Wave client... hmm? Ah, oops. Um, well...
Firefox, so... yes. Sorry. There is a... Somebody
help me. Also, that Wave from the presentation?
Um, it um yeah, there's a problem with flash
here. Okay let me try this again.
[pause]
It's always lovely to do things on other people's
computers.
[sigh]
So... I don't know why this would do this...
[pause]
Anyway, now we should see the video.
[Laughs]
[pause]
Well, you wonder how this magic is accomplished,
I'm sure. Um, let's go back to the presentation.
Maybe the video will load after a while. So!
How, how, how does it work? So if you click
the, the link, Wave creates a new, new Wave,
and uh, it inserts the Gadget that you specified,
into that Wave, underneath the content, and
this Gadget gets set in its Wavethis_referer
field. Each Gadget has a state that you can
use for anything, but for Wavethis, automatically
it writes into the Wavethis referrer field.
The URL that you got and that way, my Gadget
can then inspect the URL and see, hey, it's
coming from that YouTube page, I can extract
that videoID from that URL, and I can render
it. So, um, I'm going to have a quick look
whether it loaded; it did not. Well, that
is unfortunate. Um,
[Audience responding]
--What's that?
[inaudible]
Ok, so in this case, you have a website, and
there's a YouTube video of your cat on that
site, right? And uh you think this is so interesting
that people should share this video with their
friends. Now, you put a little Wavethis button,
under the video, if they click this button,
they get the content that you tell them to,
but they also get to see the YouTube video,
in their Wave, and then they can discuss that
with their friends, because maybe they're
not comfortable discussing that in a more
public setting.
[inaudible audience response]
So, the discussion will be on Wave, with select
groups of friends, so, to, uh, confuse the
matter, if you could compare this to, uh,
you could also put a Wave, on your website,
so that everybody can use Wave to discuss
the Video, with everybody. With Wavethis,
you do the exact opposite of that. You let
people discuss your website in, with their
friends, on Wave. Does that make sense? I
hope. Anyways, so I, um, quickly wanted to
show you the, the code of this uh, YouTube
Gadget, to give you somewhat. Oh, quick question,
who has written a Wave Gadget, or any Gadget
here? Ok, well, pay attention. Um, so, this
is just a normal Gadget, and I'm showing this,
using this, this, I've edited this little
Robot here, called Syntaxy, which is this
phenomenon thing that it actually syntax highlights
the code that you stick into Wave. Um, so
it's a, it's a normal, normal Gadget, but
in the on-state callback, we check whether
the Wavethis refer is set. Well, we first
check whether we've already loaded the movie
previously. And if the Wavethis refer is set,
we have this regular expression that we use
to extract the video ID and then here below,
we just have a standard incantation of the
normal video player and um, we um crudely
replace MovieID with the MovieID that we extracted
from the Wavethis refer. And ta-da! You have
a playing video, or rather, that should be
the case. Now, um, I also wanted to talk a
little bit about the Robot API and what you
can do with that to get content out of Wave
and and use it elsewhere. Um, so... there's,
uh, there's two Robots in the wild that are
sort of interesting, and that do this sort
of thing. One of them is Gadgitty, and the
other is Robot-Robot, that uh, let you the
first one lets you actually create a Gadget
inside of Wave. So, I can take this Robot
address, go to my Wave client, click the new
Wave... whoa. That didn't work at all. Let's
try it again. Oh... so, I added to my Contacts
that little logo, and now when I click this
thing, you see what happens is that Gadgitty
automatically inserts the boiler template
that you always need for to write a Gadget
and not only that, it um, then initiates that
same Gadget underneath there. So, you see
immediately what happens if you create this
code so I can, you know, I can try this...
wrote this Gadget here, or I can, so I can
play with it, or I can change the text here,
and save the, the situation, and then Gadgitty
will come out and um, refresh the Gadget.
Well, it doesn't work either. Um. Anyway.
So this way you have a, have a very quick
and easy way to develop a Gadget, so for all
of the people that didn't develop a Gadget
so far, give this thing a spin. It makes it
a lot easier to just get started and you get
a really, you know, a really nice interactive
feedback loop. Um, some outside developer
built the same thing for Robot. That thing
is called Robot-Robot, and um, if you want
to try your hand in Robot Development in Wave,
you should try that thing. Anyway, why is
this Waving across the Web, you might wonder?
The trick that these both Robots do is that
they um, they let you edit content in Wave,
the code for the Robot or the code for the
Gadget, and then they use Appspot to serve
up the same content at a specific URL. So
what Gadgitty do, does, is it copies from
the Wave content the the, the, bit that describes
the Gadget, and it serves that up at a specific
URL, and then the Robot inserts that Gadget
underneath the code, so you get a preview
of what you did, so that way you can dynamically
create Gadgets in, in a nice fashion. I wanted
to show you one more example of that, and
that is the, a little Robot that I wrote myself,
to create Wikis. So basically, it, the extension
introduces a little Wiki button here, and
if you type something, I want to... create
a page about London. So I select London here.
And after I click this button, the Robot gets
edits to the conversation and what the Robot
also does is, it immediately creates a, make
London into a link, to a new page, so I can
now follow this page here and you see that
there is a public Wave now, that has the title
London, and I could edit from there, and you
know, type something like, London is the capital
of the UK. And, you know, that way stitch
together a Wiki sort of thing. Funny story,
when I was developing this thing, and I was
demoing it, I did something similar like that,
and I was typing something I think like France
borders Spain. But since this Wave is public,
because you know, it's a Wiki, while I was
doing this and demoing this thing, somebody
jumped in from the wild wild Internet out
there, and started typing, it also borders
Germany. So, ha. It works, this collaborative
building of content.
[swallow]
So, um, now how does this work? I'm not going
to, oh, how does this work... I have... confused
my inbox a little with all these other Waves.
Ah, here we go.
[pause]
So, I don't want you worrying too much with
how the Wave creation itself goes, that's
just the standard trick of using annotations
and replacing annotations with a link, it's
documented on, uh, on, as, and there are samples
somewhere. I wanted to show you the other
bit where down here we register an extra handler,
saying that uh, we also serve content up at
the, at the Wiki path URL which is in this
case defined here on top it's slash Wiki.
Now, what happens is that if a request comes
in at that thing, we extract the ID, we look
up in the database that I have here, which
Wave is associated with that page, and then
we use the activerobot API to fetch that Wave
and serve it up as static HTML. So I should
be able now to go to um, uh... Wave... Wiki...
WikiWave... And, uh, see, I have now the,
I served the same Wiki page up as a static,
publicly available thing, and so with this
simple trick, we've effectively built a rather
way to collaboratively build a Wiki that we
at the same time publish as static HTML. So
I think that's kinda neat... Yes, uh, another
example that um I wanted to show you is uh,
Chess Roulette. Because I was thinking um,
you know, this guy with his video roulette,
he got a lot of reviewers, and uh, you know,
what is more popular than the chance to look
at naked people - Chess! So,
[audience laughter]
It would be a, I'm I'm going to uh try my
luck even more by challenging you to go to
this URL if you have a laptop. Of course if
you have a laptop, you're probably playing
with that, but um, now is a good time to wake
up. So if you go to this URL... and the network
works... huh.
[whisper]
This should work now.
It's chessroulette.appspot.com/play. And my
lovely insistent assistant insists I should,
what is... wrong with this clipboard here?
Anybody reach it yet?
[pause]
Really, we should do something about this
network. Ok, so, um, now somebody else should
go here, and uh.
[pause]
So what Chessroulette did is um, it uh got
the request, it uh, then took the request
um, and uh, created a new Wave, and added
me to the Wave, with that Gadget, with the
Chess Gadget. But, it also remembers that
it hasn't opened Wave, so the next person
that comes here, that would be really impressive
if that happened during my talk, um will be
automatically added to this Wave because Chessroulette
remembers that it's open and we can play Chess.
And this way you have a simple uh, gaming
engine that lets you play Chess against a
random person, which is, you know, kinda neat.
Um, no? Nobody?
[inaudible audience response]
>>OSINGA: You did. Well, then possibly my
thing has fallen off the - but did you see
me as an opponent?
[inaudible audience response]
>>OSINGA: Well, you should come up and do
this instead of me. But anyway, how impressive
is that? He played Chess against a random
person. Anyway, yeah, I'm just going to blame
as usual the network here. It's um, it's a
good trick. I think that's why we do it. Um,
so I wanted to show you a little bit of the
code on how this is, how this is done. Um...
that is, if I can find it.
[pause]
So, it's a, it's a fairly simple Robot, it's
in fact not even a Robot almost, because the
only thing that it does is, it, it registers
itself at the active API endpoint, so this
Robot can now create Waves. And then what
it does it, uh, it uses the, the, the, the,
the, the apps, app engine data store to keep
track of whether there's any uh, open chessboards,
and if so, it um, if there is an open chessboard,
then it will just, just redirect to a URL
that has that Wave embedded in it. And since
at that point the Gadget get loaded, um, and
the Gadget adds you as the, the, the next
player, because this Gadget is written in
such a way that the first two people that
look at it become white and black. So, that's,
that's just how the code, code works there.
And the only thing that uh, Chessroulette
needs to do here is, uh, is create a new Wavelet,
using the, using the active API and uh, add
this. So it's a, it's a neat little way of
creating a, a, a, a random game with a random
person, and, and and shows you off how you
can leverage the embed API for these sort
of thing. It also sort of answers one of the
questions in the thing, we'll get to that
later. Ok, I'm still not a participant here.
[pause]
The Wave Data APIs. So, this is um, I think
one of the more exciting things that we currently
have going. So we develop this Robot API and
initially it worked that it would only process
Events so it was purely Event-driven, and
uh, so you add the Robot to a Wave, then the
Robot gets a little message saying, hey, you
were added to this Wave, do you want to do
something about it. Then you press the button,
and we go out to the Robot. The Robot has
no way of contacting us. Um, so, then, to
help that, we developed a Active Robot API
and that forced us, of course, to think about
authentication, because as long as we only
make outgoing calls, we're pretty sure that
it's the Robot that we're talking to, you
know, because we start the conversation. If
it's the other way around, we're not so sure.
So, what is the standard solution for this
sort of thing; OAuth. And we use two-legged
OAuth, that is, you have to go to, in order
to get the active Robot API to work for you,
you have to go to the Registration URL for
the Robot. You enter your Robot's credentials
and then we give you a token. You have to
add this token to your Robot so that we know
that you actually control the Robot. Then
we fetch that token back from your Robot and
now we know you control the Robot, so now
we give you the secret. And you use this secret
to sign all of your requests, and that way,
we're sure that you are you. And the Google
Data, the Wave Data API, really, really sprung
from the observation that if you take this
scenario and you replace two-legged OAuth
with three-legged OAuth, you can uh, let applications
authenticate. You can, this is tricky, you
can let applications ask users for the permission
to act as them. And this is what you see in
the Twitter API and and most of our APIs.
Data APIs support that already, but the nice
thing about this trick is that, uh but this
we don't have to design an entirely new Data
API. We already have one, because the entire
Robot API is now available, and um, so today
we have um, only read-only, we're, we're going
to change that this week I think. And uh,
so basically what you can do using the Data
API is uh, search which is a new operation.
So you can get a snapshot of the Inbox of
the user, and you can, you fetch Wavelets
to get adjacent representation of the Wave.
This is simple enough, it's simple enough,
but it's powerful enough to build a really
simple Wave client, as Dhanji demonstrated.
So, I did, did that too. I built one for Android.
And I'm pretty sure I won't be able to finish
this before somebody builds a better one.
But, I'll still uh, give you a sneak preview
on how it's, how it was done. Because I...
Oh.
[whisper]
I opened the wrong panel here.
So, three-legged OAuth is called Three-legged
OAuth because it involves three legs, which
seems somewhat um, somewhat complicated. So
the way that the authentication works is,
well first of all, you have to have a whole
bunch of URLs that uh, play a part in this,
and uh, you can uh, find them in our communication.
Basically, they define where do you get the
various tokens, what is the scope of your
operation, which is in this case is Wave,
and what is the endpoint of your RPC calls.
And um, so. The way that it works is the first
thing you have to do to get three-legged OAuth
work is you call the getrequest token. This
is basically, you call the getrequest token
on, on, on Google and you say, I want to,
I want to start working with you, and I, you
set the callback URL. Now, this normally is,
the callback URL is just a normal URL, but
since this is an Android client application,
it doesn't work so well. But, since all intents
in Android can have URLS themselves, I just
define a handler that is Wave colon slash
slash Wave that makes when the browser tries
to redirect to that URL, Android jumps in
and restarts my application. So that's, that's
one, that's the first step to do. Now, the
second step to do is, uh, to start the browser
with the page that has the authentication
request in it. This will show the user in
the standard ender browser a, a, a, a, a recognizable
page with his account and the application
ID and what it wants. So in this case it will
say something like the Android Lite client
wants to have access to your Wave account,
is that okay? Then, if the users says yes,
um, three-legged OAuth will redirect me back
to, to that callback URL, which in, in turn
will restart my application. But now, in the
query parameters, it will actually have, a,
a, an OAuth token. Now, for, as soon as I
have the OAuth token, I then have to convert
it into an access token, and then I can save
the access token and the secret in the shared
state of the Android application, and I can
use that any time I want to uh, talk more
to the Wave server. So, that's uh, interesting
thing to go to. Ok that is all we have, thirteen
minutes for questions. You can find anything
about our APIs on the code.google.com URL
and of course on the bit.ly thing here. I'm
going to open that in
[whispers]
Firefox.
So, we have any questions here; please use
the microphone so that... yeah.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male #1:
Ok, if I embed a Wave in my webpage, how do
I handle hackers and spammers and all kind
of people that are going to come in and create
a nightmare of maintenance for me?
>>DHANJI:
So we, have a couple of tools for that. One
of them is that if you, if you sort of notice
the Wave going out of control, you can set
Public as Read-Only, which means that people,
your spammers can't do anything worse with
the Wave than has already been done. And then
there's this fantastic feature in Playback,
which lets you find the frame at which things
were best, right, before the spammer got on
there, and just click Restore, and then it
restores right back to that frame, and so
you can, it's as if the Spammer never existed.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #1:
Are there any clients to have something where
you can say I won't let a certain class of
people, or some sort of authentication, or
something where you can...
>>DHANJI:
Sure -
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #1:
Might I have twenty people I want to let them
do, but I don't want to keep having to turn
it off because some spammer sees this as very
popular.
>>DHANJI:
Right, um, so the question is do we have any
moderation features? We have started down
that path, so we have groups that allow you
to sort of pick a set of people, which is
exactly the same as Google groups. So, we
share the namespace as well, and you can make
a group private, which means that people that
come to your Wave, they can only see the Wave
if they've been added to that group, and being
added to a group requires you to um, get an
invitation, so, that's a pretty good.
>>Male #3:
Whoa. Careful, man.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male #4:
Sorry. I, I had a similar question about how,
like, the first thing I thought of when like
people said you can embed Waves, is, well,
what if somebody just comes along and deletes
all the comments? Um, and that could happen
a lot. That there, you know, I was just thinking,
are there plans for as far as moderation features,
something like a same-user permission idea,
where only the person who created the comment
can edit or delete it? And uh, also, um, I
guess a moderation feature for just removing
all impact from a particular user, but, I
don't know.
>>OSINGA: Yeah, so we, the first thing we
uh, can you try to get this to work? I have
no idea. The first thing we talked a lot about.
We have no concrete timeline to uh, to, to,
to get there, but um, the second thing, it
depends on how exactly, you know, if you add
a, a specific user and you set him to Read-Only,
then that user is, you know, de facto blocked
from the Wave.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
I mean, after the fact, if they've caused
a lot of damage, can you undo for a particular
user. I know that can be difficult because
it's got a tree structure, but uh -
>>OSINGA:
Yes. So, in, in theory that is actually something
that you could do because of the way that
Wave works with OT. So, you have this operation
transfer, transformation. So you could just
throw away all operations from one person,
and then, you know, just, reconstruct the
Wave.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
--Yeah, that would be awesome!
>>OSINGA:
In practice, that would of course -
AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
Of course it would make some of the operations
impossible.
>>OSINGA:
Well... It, it, it could lead to strange situations.
Technically you are correct, but still look
really weird.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
Like, what would happen if somebody responded
to them? Oh, I had another question. Um, I
can't remember what it is; I'll let somebody
else talk. Oh, that's right. Also, with um,
oh, is somebody else talking? Anyway.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male #5:
Um, does Wave support voice/video chat?
>>OSINGA:
The question is, does Wave support voice to
video chat. Um, voice... so, uh Wave natively
doesn't support it, but uh, there is a whole
bunch of extensions that let you use various
tools to do that, and um, there is uh, I think
somebody in the Wave area demonstrating an
extension that does that. So... you again.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
Second question. Yeah, me again. Uh, was okay,
so, when you embed the Wave, I mean you can
have it create a new Wave based on the URL
of the current page, right?
>>OSINGA:
Yes.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
But, I mean I can imagine situations where
you'd want to show the same Wave on different
pages or in different contexts and also situations
where maybe you would want to show different
Waves on the same page. Any plans on like
letting us just choose-
>>OSINGA:
Yes
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
An identifier for it?
>>OSINGA:
Yeah.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
Yes?
>>OSINGA:
Yeah, so this is, uh.
>>DHANJI:
So yeah, that's coming. The short answer,
it's a probably one release cycle away, which
is a couple of weeks.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #4:
Awesome.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male #6:
So, segue to his questions, uh, are you going
to in your API, will you have, uh, rights
to the participants? So, if I am the host
that started up the Wave, I would like, as
a developer, I would like to give the host
who starts the Wave controls over the rights
of the other participants.
>>OSINGA:
Yes, that is -
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #6:
Uh, Read-Only, Full-Access, No-Delete...
>>OSINGA:
Uh, so No-Delete, we don't have, but uh, we
introduced a couple weeks ago, the possibility
for Robots to set the status, set the access
rights of other participants in the Wave as
long as the Robot is indeed the entity that
created that Wave. And once we have the Data
API bit that makes it writable flipped, you
can do the same thing from the Data API perspective.
[Audience member asks question]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA: What's that?
[question continues]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA:
No, you need a Robot for that.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male #7:
Uh, I repeat the same question before, but
different way. Is there a different way to
clean a Wave? So, uh, Wave can be very messy,
and a lot of abuse. Many people can put spam
in different letters, one created the Wave,
a Wave, and I want to clean it, and then click
away all the stuff that I clean, and start
a new Wave from this clean palette, after
I clean it. So, is there some way to clean
up or take the mess out?
>>OSINGA:
Well, you can restore a Wave back to a previous
version, and you can copy a, uh, copy the
root blip to new Wave, which often is uh,
you know, if you collaborate on a document
with a team and you have all these little
in-line discussions, and then afterwards you
modify the underlying document, and then at
some point you're sort of happy with the whole
thing. And you say, okay, now I want to uh,
you can then copy it to a new Wave, and you
get a fresh copy, without the, all the entire
in-line conversations and that sort of thing
and you can modify the participant list. Plus
the, you know, so that one might be an answer
to your conundrum.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #7:
So, so, although I can, for example, take
away selective items from the Wave, only selective
items, and copy and get a new Wave out of
whatever left?
>>OSINGA:
Um, I... don't think so.
>>DHANJI:
We have a couple of features that are planned
that are similar to that, uh, where you're
able to move one thread, specifically out
or in to another Wave. So, I think that in
combination with what Douwe said earlier about
copying a Wave on, or restoring it from Playback,
that should give you all the tools that you're
looking for.
>>OSINGA: Well let me give you a, a better
answer than that, a API answer. You can build
an extension that does whatever you want.
So, if you come up with the way that you think
the cleaning should work, you build a Robot
that does that, build a little extension manifest
around it, and, you know, you create a new
button in the Toolbar. You press that button,
your Robot gets invoked. And it does whatever
you want.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #7:
Yes, but I want to sort of clean, and I think,
clean, cleaning the Wave is very important,
because it's very useful tool, but -
>>OSINGA:
I, I -
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #7:
But the issue is how to do it and keep the
Playback, but, but selectively.
>>OSINGA:
No, no, I agree that it's really important,
I'm just saying that we're working on it,
but if you want to start working on it, that
would be even better.
[chuckle]
[Unmicrophoned question]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA: Ah, yes.
[Unmicrophoned question continues.]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA:
What do you mean what is the point?
[Unmicrophoned question continues.]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA: Yeah.
[Question continues.]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA:
So the, so, yes, if you're President Obama,
you really have to watch your words, because
there is no un-saying things, and I fear that's
true on the Wave too. So, the only thing you
can do is you can remove the bits and then
copy it to a new Wave, then the new copy,
the new copy of the Wave will of course not
have the history in the Playback. But, anybody
that was on the Wave when you said the thing
that you said that you wish you hadn't will
have access to that information. That cannot
be undone. Yeah.
>>DHANJI:
Oh, and another interesting answer is, if
no one's seen that content, you can remove
them as a participant, and they'll never see
the Wave. So that's, you can actually withdraw
a Wave by doing that. And that should work
for you.
>>OSINGA:
Magic Un-Send button.
[Audience Member resumes speaking unmicrophoned.]
[inaudible]
>>OSINGA:
If you, if you add a participant to a Wave,
and uh, as long, you have, until they open
the Wave, you can remove that participant,
and they will just not see it. But, as soon
as they open a Wave, they have the information.
Yes.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male # 8:
How would you handle an embedded URL that
is um, port 443? Would you require some authentication?
So, you have the standard page, you've embedded
a URL to a site that requires authentication,
how will the Wave handle that in terms of
when it goes to that site, will it prompt
every new user who comes to the free page
to then authenticate themselves?
>>OSINGA:
Um.
>>DHANJI: Um, so if your website, it's it's
totally at the mercy of your website, right,
so if your website requires authentication
to get to a particular page -
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #8:
No, let's say it's a free website, a free--
>>DHANJI:--Okay.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #8:
- - page, and in it I embed a link to uh,
YouTube, say, that requires authentication.
Now, when someone comes to my free site and
looks at the Wave, there'll be content in
there that points to an authenticated session.
>>OSINGA:
Yes.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #8:
How will Wave deal with that?
>>DHANJI:
So, your content that you, that you link off
of the Wave is session-bound. Is that right?
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #8:
Yes.
>>DHANJI:
Well, you shouldn't do that for one thing.
[chuckle]
Because you want people to, to be able to
see it, you want, you want them to be able
to see it if they're not logged into Wave
or anything at all, right? So, ideally what
you want to do is publish your Wave in such
a way that, uh, it's the equivalent of a static
website that's out there on the Internet.
Except, the difference is you can add all
of this content inside.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #8:
Thank you.
>>DHANJI:
Thank you. Any other questions?
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER Male #9:
This is a just a follow-up on that one.
>>DHANJI:
Sure.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #9:
I mean, when you've got like the Wavethis
button, that's creating a Wave and it's embedding
a hyperlink, it's not actually drawing content
in at that point unless you've got a Gadget
that tries to do that, so all you've been
showing them is a hyperlink, and if they clicked
on it, then they'd be asked to authenticate.
>>OSINGA:
Right. Yeah, but, you know, you could have
a Gadget that only works with, like Dhanji
says, you shouldn't do that, and as the Gadget's
author if you want the people to authenticate
before using the Gadget and then you have
that Gadget, that's always going to be messy.
I mean, it can be done.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER #9:
Yeah.
>>OSINGA:
So, um, thank you very much. We're, um, out
of time.
>>DHANJI:
If you guys have more questions, come up and
see us after the talk. Thank you very much.
[Applause]
[Silence as microphones are removed.]